good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
briefly looking at today his SCP 35:58
object class safe special containment
procedures SCP 35:58 is stored in a
standard safe class containment unit
outside of testing purposes it is not to
be removed from its casing direct
contact even through layers of
protective material is insufficient to
avoid its compulsion affect all handling
of SCP 35:58 must therefore be done
using the provided pair of forceps all
handling of SCP 35:58 must take place in
the presence of at least two personnel
trained in non-lethal restraint of
lightly armed targets any individual who
succumbs to SCP 35:58 effect outside of
approved testing parameters is to be
appropriately restrained and disarmed
description SCP 35:58 is a pink
retractable box cutter of unknown make
originally acquired by the foundation at
preschool in Miami Florida
when acquired SCP 35:58 handle was
heavily stained with blood when held by
a human being SCP 35:58 compels them to
pinch one of their islets with their
free hand stretching it carefully away
from their eyeball SCP 35:58 wielder
will then carefully slide SCP 35:58
blade under the extended eyelid taking
care not to damage their eyeball they
will then perform ten to twelve
perforations along the upper part of
their eyelid followed by a single
slicing motion to excise the eyelid with
minimal damage to surrounding tissue the
wielder will then repeat these actions
on the other eyelid replacing or
removing its blade entirely produces no
change in SCP 35:58 induced behavior
suggesting that the effect is only
limited to its handle SCP 35:58
wielders exhibit no other cognitive
abnormalities aside from this compulsion
effect they will continue acting under
its influence until the object is
removed from their grip or until both
their eyelids have been entirely excised
the resultant lacerations of SCP 35:58
affected individuals will scar over more
quickly and experience lower rates of
infection compared to similarly
disfiguring facial injuries in other
subjects
it proved night vision and mild insomnia
has also been reported due to the lack
of control testing approval for such
testing from the ethics committee has
been repeatedly denied these effects
have yet to be conclusively identified
as part of SCP 35:58 anomalous
properties
okay this was an extremely short lecture
today everyone I have to apologize but I
am preparing much bigger lectures in the
future but thank you all for listening
and you were all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Andrey Pichette Pierce M
Hamlin Muslim Wookiee Jax Marik
Caleb Bowen slump God John Porter
captain Gorge Tiber ball Judi Dench
cheese whip dips Magee on dr. mortis
thank you so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos found some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you